it was leaving no one behind and i love
that i i can believe in i believed in it
and i feel like right now i'm living by
that motto
when you work in something you don't
leave no one behind you whatever you do
either a startup or a social project you
always think
for example if we're gonna think about a
startup we're gonna think about the
waste so this itself is leaving no one
behind it's not us just throwing thrash
and throwing plastic in the oceans so
it's really uh we can say us being a
good
human being in that sense
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
let's talk about impact welcome to
20-minute leaders and meet maria miziani
sustainable development project manager
muhammad 6 paul technic university
she is in charge of sustainability
community engagement as well she has
been mentoring young leaders and
starters more than 400 for more than 5
years now she is currently the executive
director and youth mobilizer at youth
sdg action campaign in morocco with the
sustainable developments youth
organization and was president and
co-founder of world married robot an
international organization that works on
the sdgs and youth empowerment where she
always conducted projects for youth
empowerment and provided impactful
opportunities for her members
marua amazian thank you so much for
joining me all the way from morocco
right yeah yeah thank you so much
thank you for the invitation
thank you thank you your work is is
inspiring to say the least because
you're working on on literally making
the world a better place you're highly
highly involved in in sustainable
development goals with the un you've in
fact won
awards you know working on on sdgs um
and today your executive director and
youth mobilizer at youth sdg action
campaign in morocco you're also the the
sustainable development project manager
at the mohammed vi polytechnic
university so really and you know all
around a lot of work with sustainable
development goals a lot of work with
startups with entrepreneurs mariah how
do you define sort of what you do
because it's not it's not a traditional
career what you're doing
well i'm gonna speak from my side in my
personal experience the first time
anybody like there was a
uh let's say an activist who talked to
me about the sustainable development
goals and i knew what is sustainable
development but not really the goals in
the agenda 2030 and so my first question
was like what are what are those what
are you talking about i don't know about
these goals but you know i think as any
other activists or any other curious
millennial old gen z i believe like all
the generations the future duration are
very curious and they have the
informations right beside them by like
typing on google on youtube and so on so
i did the same i went and looked for it
and i just really was i i was really i
felt like the agenda 2030 or the
sustainability itself
made it it was more clear it was uh
concise it had
like we can say a target has an audience
we could actually just look one goal and
be able to
pinpoint what we can do exactly so that
starts actually from
me being an activist me just want to
work on myself
me being um
we can say i just want to make myself i
wanted to make for myself a better
version for myself so i had depression i
i was like suffering from it but i at
some point i was like i need to
get my life
going so when i did that to myself and
it felt like really i can do much to
others in that sense so i started being
a volunteer in many organizations i
started being a consultant and then i
found out that i'm really good at
mentoring people and guiding people so
my journey started there because
since a young age i was really someone
who loved working and helping like
working with people and helping people
in that sense so it just made sense at
some point when i really like um
let's say as i searched and i read a lot
about sustainable it felt like i can
help people and i can help animals i can
be good to the environment to earth as
itself so it felt like it really aligns
with my personality and that which when
it really started i feel like
sustainable is not something like a
trend more like oh my god do you and the
agenda 2030 no it's a lifestyle it
should be implemented in our laws uh
it's no more a joke or it's no more
trend that we just
be like um having this one character
like the color for canvas and everything
it has to become something like in
our i'm gonna say this like it has to be
something that we live on a daily basis
that's how i see it so i started like
that me loving
helping like people and want to be there
for people either literally to be for
example helping animals or
thinking about animal welfare or helping
people who are depressed that went
through my journey we can say i just
whatever i was learning i was learning
in order to help people so it made it
really easier for
me take me back to that moment where you
got exposed for the first time uh about
sdgs and about you know what you know
try to you know help me understand
really you know what you were going
through as you were discovering this
whole world
that that previously wasn't really part
of your life
it was actually part of my life but i
didn't give it a name
i was doing my masters at that time
and um i was like very active in me with
many ngos or school clubs i was always
on the go like you can either find me in
my classes working part-time jobs or
being part of a training or trying to
organize a training for some people so
uh and there was like i was in a camp
and there was this lady she was really
like very active uh i'm really thankful
to her and she was like i work with this
ngo they are working on the sustainable
development goals and i knew i was like
i know what is sustainable about what
what are those goals so i went and
searched on google i found out that the
un actually has just
gathered all the country leads the
president so they can agree on on the
unleashing the agenda 2030 on the 20th
to 2015 but i i met that lady in 2016 so
it was like more like a five five months
i guess or six months after the after
the luncheon or we can say after the the
un reform
so yeah i started searching on google i
started like talking to people in the
the first phase actually the ngo that
won the unsdg action campaign we were
that team like all of us from different
backgrounds you can find me here like
with a scientific background someone
with a low background someone for
example with the sustainable development
background and they came together and we
were like okay since for example i was i
didn't know what are those goals let's
make sure that everyone knows what are
those goals and how can we help them if
we have for example an ego that works on
we can say for example uh environmental
action we can tell them that they are
actually working on the sdg 13 if they
are working on education or education
rule or girls in in some part for
example in morocco then they are working
on gender equality and they are working
on the sdg number four quality education
so is digi number four is digi number
five so we made sure that we go around
the kingdom of morocco in order to
appoint ambassadors of this campaign and
let people know what are those issues
and what is what is the vision of the
agenda 2030
what i really loved about the agenda
itself it was a more of a personal
vision no not me being like part of the
a you animation or a vision it was more
like the motto that was behind it
it was leaving no one behind and i love
that i i can believe in i believed in it
and i feel like right now i'm living by
that motto
when you work in something you don't
leave no one behind you whatever you do
either a startup or a social project you
always think
for example if we're gonna think about a
startup we're gonna think about the
waste so this itself is leaving no one
behind it's not us just throwing thrash
and throwing plastic in the oceans so
it's really uh we can say us being a
good
human being in that sense so yeah i
started doing that uh we can talk later
on where i where we try to implement
like effective and concrete actions
because we cannot just keep talking and
saying what are those hdz's since the
information is pretty everywhere you can
find it on google and podcasts so we're
like okay so we have to start
making it or implementing concrete
actions in what's better than
entrepreneurship or social
entrepreneurship so
i worked with a lot of ngos in that
sense i
i started mentoring like students or my
colleagues
in order for their startup to be
sustainable so for example if they're
working on a any kind of subject let it
be energy or
uh textile or whatever that is i need to
make sure that the sustainable
development touch has to be there
so it's more like you can see that it
comes from the heart it's not something
that we have to make it to make our
speech beautiful or oh my god we care
about the environment in the word no it
has to come from the heart it
and they say also when you work on
something in you it's it's it is your
passion you feel like you're not working
like you don't feel like working you
feel like you're living your life so
it's pretty much my life i live my
passion every day throughout like with
the mohammed tech polytechnic university
or the youth sdg action campaign i so
most of the time i don't feel tired
until my my health gives out because i'm
living my passion and i try to do the
same with everyone like i'm trying to
help them find their passion in order
for them
like to give it like to give it their
all so they can actually either develop
their personality
or they can either for example find out
what what
what what is their mission on earth and
when i speak about this i'm going to
speak about the other half is that i
really love working on youth empowerment
i love when since i was president of a
lot of ngos
when i worked with youth and i was also
someone who was lost at some point in my
life and i was like i don't know what
i'm gonna do because i was doing med
school and then i stopped it and then i
did science it was all over the i was
all over the place but at some point i
was lost and i needed someone to help me
to mentor me so i didn't find it was
pretty hard the mentorship or the
mentor-mentee relationship or status
here in morocco is not really that
something that is really like we can say
it's it's pretty um known like they
don't know that you should have mentors
like either they can even not be
moroccan they can be international i
have a mentor from mit and i have a
mentor who is way younger than me and i
have a metro who is way older than me so
either each one of them are going to
teach me in their uh in their sense or
their vision so i can
like gather all the informations and
make it my own or or have my own
conclusion or have my own vision me
based in my experience or their
experience so i can have a better
version or a better vision in life i
don't know how i'm going to explain it
but that's what i try to do i try to
mentor them i try to be their mentor
either for example for their mental
health or
just me saying okay you have the
potential please go work on this for
example there was this student who is
really into engineering but at some
point he i felt like he's
really like just losing his time or
wasting his time i can say
and i was like but he was really good in
mental health subjects he was so into
those he was so into whenever we talk
about a mental health issue or
or a disease
he would be the one knowing all about it
so he's like why don't you try studying
like uh psychology that made really
interests you and he did that and he's
not like the happiest he can help people
better he's like our uh we can say he's
like our psychologist now so he's always
helping us he's always making it better
he knows what he's saying and it's his
passion so
i really love doing that i feel like
whenever i was lost at that time and me
helping people who were lost and now
they with one sentence or one
we can say coffee we just uh
meet in a coffee shop and we can talk
like very like in a friendly uh we can
say in a friendly uh sitting it doesn't
have to be
very professional just could be a cup of
coffee a cup of tea and can just sit
down and talk and me listening to you
and me guiding you throughout like what
i can see that it would be better for
you but of course the decision is gonna
stay yours it has to be yours because
it's your life it's not mine so yeah uh
and it all goes around to sustainable
development because whenever we talk
about sustainable development we talk
about human beings because the agenda
2030 is for who it's for us it's for us
to be good to each other it's for us to
be good to nature it's for us to provide
uh to uh for us to be able to um like
use goods but not compromising the needs
or the goods for the future generation
so it always comes back to us being good
to each other in that in that sense
beautiful beautiful
paint me a picture of of morocco today
and how morocco is dealing with the sdgs
and sort of you know is this something
that is becoming mainstream how what is
your experience with with sort of
penetrating into the ecosystem and
bringing sort of this new this new idea
that that shouldn't be new but but it is
new after all
uh morocco now actually
i think everyone knows these diseases
and i feel like i i always feel proud
when i say this because at that time
nobody knew and i was someone who didn't
know like i feel like there was just if
we can say 10 people or 20 people at
2016 who knew who for example the people
who are following the un reports and in
such as but even like the the most
active youth at that time didn't know
about it
so now everyone knows we helped actually
associations or ngos in order for them
to know which is digits they are working
for or which is dishes they are
specialized in like we could talk with
organizations sit down with them get to
know what is their vision and then we
tell them look you're working on these
sdgs you these these targets are due and
for example website can help you uh
perform better or have better kpi's in
that sense so morocco now we can call it
green morocco because it is actually the
vision of the mass majesty the king the
majesty his majesty was was always
talking about a green morocco so it was
we can say a mindset since forever since
i was a young
young child
so uh i grew up with that i grew up with
hearing speeches about green morocco
a greener morocco a better morocco
so when it comes to its disease the
as you can see uh there is
uh morocco is actually one of the top
performing
countries in africa and when it comes to
climate change worldwide
so
the last climate change index we are
actually at the fifth uh position
worldwide when it comes to us like being
a country that is mostly uh actively
working against like the emissions in uh
um fighting against climate change and
it's it's actually it comes around the
fact that we are working so hard on
making a clean energy
and this i'm going to bring back also my
work with the muhammad's polytechnic
university because uh they have a green
energy park like a park just for green
energies just for clean energy when it
comes to terms of research and so on so
i feel like morocco is getting like uh
we can say innovative creative i can see
definitely that us as youth leaders we
are a generation that is very confident
in what we have because um
the existence of us for example uh we
can say
a lot of
how i'm gonna say this so you study you
are a student and you have a lot of
clubs and you get to be exposed to the
right uh people in that sense so you get
inspired so you get active in that sense
so once you get inspired you're like oh
my god she did it why can't i so they
become become they become active for
example in students clubs or
associations and then they become
even better active leaders and they they
can even get jobs while studying so this
is the generation that i'm i'm seeing
right now in morocco and i have like a
lot of hope when it comes to this
because i feel like
if we have uh a society that is polio
like i'm gonna multidisciplinary so we
have low for example students who know
everything about climate justice for
example or we have scientists who know
how to manage projects so if we have a
generation that is they can just get a
glimpse of what is management while
being very technical in engineering and
so on we are creating really like a
strong generation in that sense and i
feel i feel like
uh the government it's not really like
the role of governments in this and i
feel like it's our role it's us as youth
or us as uh we can do that since i've i
was able to develop my personality in a
sense i can do the same with others you
see
definitely and i have to say
mariah that i've had quite a few
you know people on this show and and
i've yet to meet somebody who's so
who has such deep conviction as to what
they do that's i think just the right
way to to put it like the way that the
conviction that you have
in what you do and why you do it and the
impact that you're going to have on the
world and that you need to have in the
world i think that's inspiring where do
you draw
for yourself the inspiration on a
day-to-day basis to feel what you're
feeling here
um i actually um have it from the
stories that i have
like when i start being active i can
remember a student i was given like i
was tutoring i was a tutor so i can have
like some money so i can be active in
associations because i was very
independent and i remember one time
a mom wanted to get her her daughter out
of school
she was like the school is not for you
since you're a girl and we still have
that mindset management sadly we still
have that mindset and i was like that's
not gonna happen because she came to me
she talked to my sister and she came to
me and i was like no that's not gonna
not on my watch as they say so i went to
the mom and i told her just give me one
month with her
and if she didn't succeed in her exams
then you can do whatever you want
so i took my time in that month i i
taught her everything that i can like on
a daily basis she was coming to my house
every day so i can tutor her
you cannot imagine the mark that she had
just because i believed in her just
because i was able to convince her mom
and i forgot about that so i did that
she actually succeeded in her in her
year she was able to join high school
because she was in middle school and she
had to go to high school
and three years later i was with mom uh
going out like shopping and there was
this girl out of nowhere she came to me
and hugged me and i was like what is
what's going on i don't know what's
going on and she was like i don't know
if you remember me but i will remember
you my whole life you are the one
everything what i'm doing is is because
of you is thanks to you you're the one
who made me i just got my baccalaureate
diploma i just graduated from high
school and i'm gonna go do english
studies because you're the one who made
me love english and i was able to do all
of that just because you believed in me
so whenever i feel down because a weird
human
i always remember stories like that like
i was able to do it's not there are a
lot of stories and sometimes i feel
proud that i was able to do so because
at that time i didn't i wasn't sure i
was like am i doing this okay did i am i
going to like cause her problems with
her with her family but i'm like no she
has to be educated education is
everything and it like as girls
sometimes the diploma really protect the
girl once you have a diploma you can do
whatever you want you don't have to be
like uh
sometimes when we deal with for example
abused women they cannot leave the
abused
household
just because they don't have a diploma
to work with or they can't afford from
themselves so a diploma itself is a
protection for that girl so that was my
conviction at that time so i feel like
whenever i fell down and whenever i feel
like tired i always remember these
stories that i was able to do so so i
can keep going like that i can save a
lot of people i can change um
people to just with one word one
sentence just telling them i relate i
was there i was also depressed i have
anxiety i have public speaking phobia
but i keep speaking to people it doesn't
have to stop you no you can do it like
you just have to try and let's discover
how what's what's blocking you so it has
to be that way of course i'm not a
professional therapist but sometimes i
refer them to therapists in the in that
sense but at least when someone relates
when someone believe in you i feel like
that's the key that's really the key
so yeah i think that's it that's what i
get my
daily inspirational mantra
um
i really want to thank you for for a
wonderful conversation that leaves me
energized and inspired by your
generosity and your kindness and your
your outlook
on life and our role in it and your role
as a catalyst
for the sdgs and for the goals that were
set out by the united nations so thank
you very very much best of luck with
your mission
i look forward to seeing the incredible
things that you're doing and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you thank you
thank you so much michael for your time
it was it was a good talk of course
thank you very much take care bye